odds are if you've been on Tick Tock or
Twitter as of late you've seen this new
drug ozempic be mentioned I've actually
seen Elon Musk tweet about it it's been
covered in the New York Times it's
literally everywhere so it's about time
that we talk about the truth when it
comes to ozempic for those who don't
know ozempic is a medication that's been
FDA approved to be used in patients who
have diabetes to help control blood
sugars and as an added effect decrease
the likelihood of major cardiovascular
events and have increases in weight loss
because of this added effect of weight
loss many people started using the
medication off label for just weight
loss the pharmaceutical company decided
to take the same generic medication
found within ozempic called semiglutide
increase its dosage and repackage it
under a different brand name called
wagovi and seek FDA approval as a weight
loss medication to be used in Junction
with lifestyle changes for individuals
who are either obese or overweight but
also who have one weight related
diagnosis like hypertension high
cholesterol Etc and after so many people
started getting ozempic prescribed for
this off-label use for weight loss it
exploded in popularity mostly on
television and on Tick Tock with people
claiming that they've lost huge amounts
of weight talking about their successes
and as a result of all this publicity
there was literally a run to doctors to
prescribe this medication for them off
label in order to help them with their
weight loss which unfortunately ended up
creating a shortage which puts people at
risk who desperately need the medication
because they have a true diagnosis of
diabetes and are not using it for
off-label uses there is a huge rise of
misinformation happening at this very
moment that we have to fact check
this claim is patently untrue and anyone
saying this has a terrible understanding
of how ozempic semiglutide actually
works this medicine actually works as an
appetite suppressant that slows or
delays gastric emptying therefore you
feel full and you have less of an
appetite so it's more of an appetite
modulator leading you to consume less
calories therefore losing weight not oh
I can eat 10 pizzas and take this
medication and not absorb the calories
you see how there's a very important
difference here because if you eat a lot
of food and take this medication that
slows your gastric emptying it's going
to make you feel worse and you're going
to have more side effects more nausea
more vomiting more potential diarrhea
and constipation people are actually
talking about these side effects who are
eating their normal portions or even
eating reduced portions so imagine if
you were to overeat thinking you can
while taking this medication that's a
cause for concern
this claim is starting to spiral out of
control because it initially started
with some simple observations that
doctors made of their patients who were
losing weight on ozampic or wagovi and
they were seeing that those patients
were losing body fat but they were also
losing lean muscle mass this is not
surprising because the way these
medications work is by suppressing
appetite therefore having the patient
consume less calories anytime you're
going to be consuming less calories you
will both lose muscle mass and body fat
this is obviously not ideal but with
this type of medication that control is
limited but we do have control any good
doctor should not be just prescribing
this medication and forgetting about the
patient a you're supposed to be getting
the medication and having the doses
slowly increase based on the effects and
side effects that we're seeing also it
should come with a plan for nutrition
possibly meeting with a nutritionist who
can help guide you as to how much
protein you should be taking in despite
the fact that you consuming less
calories and a plan for exercise that
includes resistance and weight training
to help keep on some of that lean muscle
mass
this is the one where I'm seeing the
most examples of on Tick Tock someone
saying oh I took ozempic for a wedding
and I lost 10 pounds look how great I
look this is not what the medicine was
intended for in fact people who are
already of a healthy weight looking to
get skinnier were not the ones that were
studied when we were checking the safety
and effectiveness of this medication so
maybe taking it while you're already at
a healthy weight can lead to worse side
effects and the worst part of all of it
once you stop taking it the weight will
come right back this type of yo-yo
dieting has been associated with
numerous health risks including
returning to your normal weight and then
going past it and gaining even more
weight after you stop a medication like
this
anytime you have a rapid type of weight
loss what can happen is you lose the
subcutaneous fat that's present in your
skin especially if in your 30s or 40s
and as a result you can develop this
hollowed out appearance to your face now
if you're taking ozempic or wigovi the
correct way this shouldn't be happening
my suspicion is the people who are
experiencing this quote-unquote ozempic
face or this hollowed-out look are
individuals who are rushing to lose
weight using it in a way that is not
being prescribed to them because when
doctors prescribe these medicines they
do it with a titration mindset meaning
they start low and they slowly increase
your dose while monitoring how much
weight you're losing how many side
effects you're experiencing ideally what
doctors are looking for is for a
continued one to two pound weight loss
per week obviously that varies depending
on your own individual situation but
certainly not the 10 15 pounds in one
week that people are claiming they've
lost on these medications when they're
using them in a non-prescribed
uncontrolled way
[Music]
I don't think glp-1 medication should be
first-line treatments for those who need
to lose weight anytime you're
prescribing a medication there needs to
be a risk benefit ratio done for the
individual sitting in front of you and
ultimately the individual needs to
decide if the medication is right for
them and while these medications have
shown promise for individuals to lose 10
to 20 percent of their weight if they
are overweight or obese it's still
important to factor in that there are
legitimate risks to taking these
medications there are side effects
people have GI issues nausea vomiting
diarrhea constipation pancreatitis
kidney issues there is a potential issue
of increases in thyroid cancer long term
with these medications and these are not
reasons to not take the medicine these
are reasons to think about this medicine
as a tool in our Arsenal to help
patients reach their desired weight and
when we talk about their desired weight
that talks about a health healthy weight
to me I feel like this whole
conversation has caused us to lose sight
of the big picture with the exception of
an individual who's facing harsh
socioeconomic standing someone who has a
legitimate medical condition like
diabetes or a thyroid condition among
the many others that cause increased
weight weight loss or weight gain is
under our control there are things that
we can do and I could recommend as a
doctor to help someone lose weight when
it comes from when it comes to a
nutrition standpoint a fitness
standpoint sleep mental health Etc when
I think about my patient's health I
don't just think about their weight
weight is not the sole determinant of
one's health and when it comes to
improving someone's lifestyle we're not
only lowering the weight we're also
improving their quality of life
decreasing risks of certain cancers
other diseases and ultimately extending
and prolonging their lives that's what
being a doctor is about not just
focusing on the scale
I actually had a patient whose doctors
said all of their symptoms were due to
their weight and I actually found that
wasn't the case at all click here to
check that out and as always stay happy
and healthy
foreign